a little Miss hate video yeah
[Laughter]
yeah for all the money everything
yeah any ideas
my questions
sorry sorry I said I should I didn't say
my question to you was what part of the
hate comments resonated with you to
where you were like okay why does this
hurt me I think it hurt me because I
love men
and obviously what those men were taking
from the episode was that I don't like
men and misandrist and they were saying
oh this is why she'll be single forever
and I'm like I I I have men you know and
I love them so it's like why are you
coming from me in that way like making
me feel like I'm I have no value just
because I'm I'm talking about my
opinions and stuff so I think that's
what really got me because I don't want
to be seen like I'm anti-men do you know
what I mean that's not what I'm about
like I'm just about
um women having their rights women
having their autonomy that's it but men
do your thing your kings we love you you
know that's kind of what I want to be
known for and I think I didn't like that
I was seen in that lie and it made me
think is it the stuff I said are they
misconstruing what I said do you know
what I mean right it's definitely what
you said and how you said it yeah what
do you think I said that and I'll tell
you why because I watched the interview
as well and I'll compare myself to you
because me and you I've listened but you
get hate too though listen all the time
exactly I'm the Troublemaker for a
reason because I come here and every
single time on one on one of the
episodes is people saying I've had
people approach me in in life in real
life to say to me you're you're
basically 13 now and you ain't got a man
I need to take you to my church and they
were actually quite
intentionally haterific in my face but
guess what this is the thing I really
don't care because what I believe is my
truth and whatever people are telling me
doesn't stick to me because their hate
towards me is more sometimes of a
reflection of themselves because they
cannot understand how the novel can say
all these things I still feel good about
herself I don't really care if
somebody's telling me I'm 30 I'm gonna
be on my own and I don't have a man
because my truth is that if I want to be
with somebody I can work for it but the
thing about it I reflect on myself a lot
I feel like everyone should and if you
feel like you're doing something wrong
and if a lot of people are saying the
same thing
I have to think wait am I doing the
right thing is what they're saying right
so I think obviously I have
self-confidence in myself yeah but I
also need to reflect and actually think
okay I know what I believe in am I being
delusional you know why would you take
that offense [ __ ] you why would you take
offense to it if someone's like telling
you something you can either if you know
yourself you can be like okay they don't
know what they're talking about or you
can take it assess it take what they
said
um and then leave the pieces that you're
like yeah no that's not me why would you
get
offended by something because when I
first came on the show they didn't like
me at all and I was just like well I
don't know why they don't like me or I
would listen to what they were saying I
was like okay well maybe I should listen
more take what they say and say and do
things differently or say things
differently and understand from them and
if they're speaking a little rubbish I'm
like okay y'all don't know what you're
talking about go on with your life but I
don't think there you should get
offended first of all is the internet
they everybody gonna say whatever they
want to say you know people always say
it's the Internet it's life we bump the
Internet it's life people are killing
themselves because of the internet like
we need to stop people are killing
themselves outside of the internet you
know things kind of talking to your mic
a little closer we need to have a bit of
censorship because people just keep
saying it's the internet is the internet
what like when I came on the show it was
so overwhelming like so much like but
why are you coming
you also made the choice like like you
were talking most of the the show and
there's people that come on they don't
really know what type of show it is and
they're just they just keep quiet
they're like I can see the shock in
their face in there and they're no I I
know but I'm saying like if you see the
type of environment you don't like it
you can always just opt out and not say
like I've had people I was gonna leave
as soon as like I was like okay this is
that type of but then you're just
walking out you're gonna leave it's like
you're walking out of a situation it's
like right then I look back because I'm
like oh she can't hold her but then you
also
you could have just been quiet and said
okay like what I've maybe been offended
silently and then just when they're a
camera moved just walked out like
there's girls that have done that it's
not like I don't force anyone to be here
yeah I'm not gonna lie I didn't know the
type of environment was I didn't even
know I was coming on the show Eddie I'm
gonna call you out Eddie reached out to
me and I thought I was going on his
podcast and then obviously I was here so
I didn't know this was gonna happen I
didn't know obviously now that I know
that's when you invited me for this
episode I understood what it's about and
it's like okay don't take anything
personal and obviously I have a podcast
when I have guests come on my on my show
I'm very like I care about how they feel
because I I I'm I'm a massive believer
in protecting people's mental health
because I've seen what people go through
like people want to kill themselves
because of this stuff and I don't want
to contribute towards it and I don't
care if it's an entertainment I do not
[ __ ] care we need to protect people's
mental health and that's how I I run my
show and a lot of shows that I've been
on stand-up TV I've got a lot of history
how are you wait wait Harry was like
guys please just checking is everyone
okay obviously I didn't get that from
you and it was just a very like well
actually but do you realize do you
realize you no one forced you to say
anything no one forced you to put
yourself out that you were saying the
thing so how is
because Pearl didn't reach out to you to
see if you were okay because everything
happened no no no no no no no I know
you're not a bit toxic but you you were
saying things like Pearl said if you if
you didn't want people to come after you
you could have just set back but you
kept my followers I didn't know no no it
doesn't it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if you don't know the followers
it's life people are gonna come at you
no matter what internet off the internet
so if you don't want people coming at
you it's just like okay sit back not say
anything it's just it's just an
accountability thing like I just feel
like like when Andrew was talking about
how everything in life is your fault I
literally believed that yeah because
it's like like you know when that when
that girl came on and she like got a
couple points on me and honestly like I
felt like she was just arguing like I
just felt she came in like he did right
and like ready to say all this stuff and
I just wasn't prepared but like instead
of saying oh like she click baited me
she did this this and this I'll be like
you know what I wasn't prepared I'll
take my I'll I'll let her get her Tick
Tock Cloud off of it but it's it's like
take accountability is I should have
asked more questions daddy so when Eddie
was like oh you want to come on a
YouTube channel and that's literally
what he said a YouTube channel about
relationships I should have asked which
YouTube channel is because he's a
podcaster he has a podcast I just assume
sister what was stopping you when you
got here
um
that was a show okay okay but like what
was stopping when you got here and you
realized it wasn't the his podcast from
like Googling the podcast you were on I
didn't Google it because we're already
here but it started I know I know but
I'm saying I'm saying you could you you
usually get like a half hour before the
show starts people like will chill out
hang out whatever so you could look up
the podcast you could see the titles
within five minutes of research and I've
had people do that and leave leave yeah
yeah you live and you learn and this is
why I will never accept any invitation
to any show any podcast until I know
exactly what I'm walking really
that's the truth every single time
especially for when it comes to the
internet you know one thing there'll be
people that like you there'll be people
that don't like it especially if you
don't have an opinion that is strong
whatever that opinion is be ready to
face the backlash when because I met you
through Castillo when I went on his show
I knew that was a possibility that
people go against me because I come with
a different personality and I'm always
ready the moment the camera is on I know
the consequences of my actions so there
is no excuse to go somewhere and be like
the camera is on and now your hate is
that your followers are haters and now
you are this and you have that you go on
that you be ready for anything it's
Showbiz I have to keep bringing it back
you're Sagittarius
no I'll tell you the difference Pisces
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
sign you are okay no no no no wait wait
wait wait wait actually wait wait wait
wait wait you should say she said you're
a Pisces she's a Pisces so why is she
okay because you didn't come for her
there was nothing like if anything if
anything Britney has more of a reason to
hate me than anyone here
but I'm still attacked no I mean no I
didn't feel attacked I felt like because
Pearl is not in my situation I feel like
it's easy to be like oh well you know
you made a mistake because let's go back
to what she said during the podcast
which is we were talking about the the
kids stuff she's like well you made a a
poor choice these are the repercussions
I can see how you feel that way but like
let me try to break it down for you so
you can understand so I I get it it's
like if you're not it's it's all fun and
games until it's you so that's where for
me like it's it's not even like oh she's
coming for me I'm just trying to explain
to her this is my perspective it takes
two to tango don't put all that on me
you know what I mean because it at the
end of the day I open my legs and I can
have a baby or not but I can't have a
baby without semen you know so yeah I
didn't I didn't feel like I I feel like
Pearl's inner like her her style too
like I've told her
um before I actually like really like
the past few days did like a deep dive
watching all of you guys like really
getting into it like I felt like there
there was this unlikable quality to her
because she wasn't she was not gonna say
her personal experience but she's gonna
ask a question that you're like girl
you're a woman why are you trying to go
against us but like I feel like it still
poses for good conversation and when I
watched her wife school when I really
like was talking to her outside of it
I'm like I could see her personality so
I feel like understanding her
personality and then when it comes time
in here to interview it is you're gonna
get a little bit of a different person
if you did a research you know right but
it doesn't take long to research me it's
the same boat
no no no no no no
yes
no because you've talked a lot let me
stop it for two seconds because this is
the truth what I don't like and what I
will not stand for is somebody that
actually had the exact same experience
as me be upset because you could not
handle it with the substance of the
woman that you are Pearl and anybody on
this on this podcast what they did to
you that night is they won you lost
every time no it is it is
no no you're cutting me off and this is
the problem that they had with you then
because you're not willing to listen to
where you went wrong you went wrong
because you were not strong enough in
your opinion I've come here I've got way
more hate than you way more hating you
all the super chats every single comment
on there is about the Navajo delusional
she'll end up on her own I'm older than
you so on top of that I'm even more of a
Target I'm single too so I've had that
sort of attitude in fact on that same
day that I came Sarah came for me a man
came for me and he told me a lot of
things and I held my own why because as
a woman I stand on my own two feet I
believe my truth and they know thing
that nobody can tell me one or two that
can make me change my mind because I
know who I am if you're coming on the
internet and you're going to put your
voice out there be sure that you know
who you are because people come to you
and if you doubt yourself that's why it
goes wrong your problem is that you are
weird to come here no it was it's about
I'm not I'm not here to argue it was a
podcast I I thought we were all just
talking about how our opinions I didn't
know it was gonna what if someone
doesn't agree with your opinion
right you're not agreeing with me it's
okay but it's when you're saying my
faith is weak okay so hold on hold on
hold on I wanna I wanna go to that hold
on as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible